prince philip a man much admired
always upright and strong immaculate
perfectly attired
he seemed to put no foot wrong
it's a chance to remember a man they
grew up with
residents at woodland court care home in
torquay
are preparing to pay their respects to
prince philip
he always seemed to be upright and
strong and he wasn't
hiding or kind of um
i don't know he just seemed to be
genuine 93 year old cyril
met the prince when he visited devon
it's only just come to light
what he really did when he was alive i
mean all the things
that he was capable of and all the
visits he made to
different places and things he did
i mean he was always in the background
of the queen
and i'm sure she's going to miss him
terribly
with large gatherings still banned many
will be marking the moment in their own
way
thank you very much no problem the
babacam inn will be halting service
at three o'clock joining the nation in a
minute's silence
i shall be at home with a beer
sat down with my dear wife and we'll be
watching it
yeah we will be sorry to miss him well i
should be watching it you know
and um you know i think he'll be very
emotional to be honest
yeah i think he was a wonderful man i
think just taking a moment to reflect
and i think
hopefully they will have nice weather
and it will just be a moment to sort of
stop and
take stock celebrate
there will be little pomp and ceremony
while many people will be watching the
funeral from home or raising a pint in
the local pub
for younger generations they may be
spending their saturday preparing for
his award
as the duke's legacy lives on
ashley hohn has helped run the duke of
edinburgh awards scheme
for 18 years i think the duke would want
them to
to continue doing what they're doing to
be positive
to broaden their horizons to seek new
experiences
and to remember that his legacy should
enable them to
to have access to that any events on
saturday
will be low-key just as the prince would
have wanted
regardless the nation will pause to
remember
a lifetime of service prince philip
good luck yeah well done david an
officer
sky news in torbay